this is a look into the British future
it's the first hot clinic to open in UK
and what all GPS might have to end up
doing during this pandemic everyone who
comes here has coronavirus symptoms so
they take extraordinary precautions to
protect themselves the patient who's
struggling to breathe is now in the red
zone in a world locked down against this
deadly virus this is a very lonely
battle it's clear he's frightened and
weak the GP here is the first point of
healthcare for virus patients and this
patient in obvious discomfort but the
doctor decides he's not ill enough to
send him to a hospital which is already
stretched how are you feeling sir
[Music]
what do you think but all they can do is
wait to see if he gets worse and hope he
doesn't infect too many others there's a
strict disinfecting procedure after
every patient see and everyone here
knows there's a level of risk this GP
group bought their own extra protective
equipment weeks ago including reusable
plastic goggles they know they're
luckier than many in the rest of the
country even so they'll probably get
infected I think because the virus
exposure is all there and I think so
it's just a matter of and hoping that we
get the lesser form of it but in this GP
surgery this is their uniform now with
much equipment they brought themselves
and visors donated by the University
Medical Hospital and they're urging all
their colleagues to protect themselves
many GPS we just welcome to don't have
the protective equipment so a huge
number of GP appointments are done
remotely this trainee GP who volunteered
in the hospital casualty told us that in
one 10-hour shift ambulances brought
virus patients every 15 minutes
how does your family feel about you
doing it OLF was kid like a hawk hope I
don't have a table set should I you
really sure you want to go back yes I
have to do it from City IPL school and
be sending patients and Yahoo don't go
there
it doesn't make sense right we just have
to go there
you can keep making phone calls yes yeah
be sent to the GP surgery and then our
quick selfie just have to go there is an
emotional toll on these health workers
the fear is real and the virus has yet
to peak Alex Crawford Sky News
stoke-on-trent